all right guys bang bang i'm very
excited to talk to michael here uh i
feel like the best place to start is
just the importance of philosophy uh i
think a lot of people have probably
heard of philosophy maybe even taking a
class in college or in high school but
they kind of threw it out they don't pay
attention to it anymore uh you spent a
ton of time uh studying this and also uh
understanding why maybe some of your
thoughts your ideas have been
blacklisted or kind of blackballed from
uh kind of traditional academia so why
are you so interested in philosophy and
why do you feel like it's so important
to really understand this
well people have whatever impression of
philosophy they have from their first
year classes or people they know who are
into philosophy and maybe at times it
can seem like hair splitting or logical
exercises that don't really matter very
much
but in fact i believe and will argue
that there's a lot at stake in how we
think philosophically especially about
politics so political philosophy is that
part of philosophy that thinks about
things like what is justice what is the
best way of living together what's the
best way of life
what's the relationship between violence
and power and all of those kinds of
things so we know that we're affected
all the time by law for the better or
for the worse depending on whether the
laws are good or bad by power by
domination and these kinds of things so
political philosophy raises those issues
and gets us to think clearly about them
so that's one thing another is that the
classical political philosophers they
thought that philosophy as a way of life
is the happiest way you can live
so some people chase money not that
there's anything wrong with that
some people chase honor they want to be
recognized they want to have maybe
eternal fame you know as a great
conqueror or as a legislator you know
like a founding father type status
but the question what is a happy life
what is happiness is right at the
beginning of the philosophical tradition
so aristotle plato they inquire into
philosophy as a way of life and argue
that's where you can feel most fulfilled
and that's sort of the peak of human
existence in a way
so when we look around at the woke state
of affairs today and at all of the
craziness if you scratch beneath the
surface of that you can find
philosophical disputes about again who
is the human being what does it mean to
live well and what's possible
politically
so
we need to think clearly we're facing
really big challenges and we don't want
to be careless in assessing them so a
lot of people deal with that at the
economic level at the legal level and
the philosophical level just gives us a
comprehensive overview of what the big
issues are and as i say walks us through
what the smartest people in our history
have had to say about them in a way that
we can resonate with and learn from
as i've learned more and more about
philosophy about stoics and many other
things that we'll just throw in the
bucket of kind of intelligent people
throughout history you learn that many
of the problems we face today likely
aren't as new as we'd like to think that
they are as you've looked backwards how
does it give you a better understanding
of what we're actually facing today and
as you describe some of the insanity of
uh what people are feeling in day to day
life
this point you just brought up is
crucial because it can seem like we live
in unprecedented times everything is
always totally new there's a new crisis
on the horizon or we're in the middle of
one as though nobody's ever faced
anything similar and it's reasonable why
people could think that way like we have
all of these new technological
developments and advancements we have
nations of such a huge scale not like
small ancient democracies or something
and you might just think there's no
commonality between us and somebody who
lived 2500 years ago what could we
possibly learn from plato or aristotle
for example but one of the beautiful
things you don't even have to read very
much
you can read the first few pages of
plato's republic the first little bit of
aristotle's politics for example and
you'll see that this distance in time
between us
now and them then just collapses so it's
not like everything is the same but what
becomes interesting is what is constant
in political and human life
because if there are constants then we
may be able to find some guidance some
answers about our current problems when
we turn to those older thinkers
well that's just the most rewarding
thing you can do so for me personally it
was actually pretty funny in my first
philosophy class i hadn't had this
experience yet okay of collapsing the
distance between us now and my professor
said something along the lines of the
fact that the romans also had graffiti
in their bathroom stalls okay something
like that some comment and it just
clicked in my mind that the same types
of people we have now you know this
guy's gonna be a clown this guy's an
oddball this guy's a genius this guy's a
poet another person oriented religiously
that all of these types
they're they can be represented
in the old accounts as well
so for me reading plato reading
aristotle reading those old philosophers
it also allows us to get questions clear
that today are forbidden they're off the
table
in some sense so you know and your
listeners know we live in a time where
you have all kinds of enforced
ideological orthodoxies
what if you want to think about the
alternatives well first of all socrates
thought about some alternatives i don't
know how much people know his backstory
he raised questions about the law about
justice he eventually was killed okay he
was found guilty of corrupting the youth
of not believing in the gods of the city
you could say not believing in the
ruling ideology
and he was sentenced to death so in the
very life of socrates for example we
don't even have to go to the stokes and
just studying the life of socrates
we learn about the potential conflict
eternally built in
to the nature of political life
versus people who try to think about it
you know because political life demands
a certain kind of obedience to authority
that is incompatible with free thought
it's incompatible with philosophizing
well that gives rise to a genuine
tension
and some people say well you know just
everybody should be able to think openly
what they want and say openly what they
want
but we learn from plato's writings and
from the life of socrates that it's not
so simple
you need law to live together in a
political community but law has its
power as a function of our habit of
obedience to it so if you're constantly
criticizing the law in public you are
removing that habit of obedience to the
law you see and so it like the
philosophers
pose a threat
to the political community and vice
versa the political community poses a
threat to the philosophers
the philosophers cast doubt on the
orthodoxies and the political city tries
to kill the free thinkers this is a
long-standing problem you know
as relevant today as it was then how do
you think about uh the balance in what
is supposed to be free democratic
societies today uh where free speech is
not only encouraged but it is protected
uh we know from the lessons of history
that those who critiqued criticized or
even just pontificated
new and alternative ideas
they were seen as that threat they were
treated as a threat and sometimes
ended up either being jailed killed or
other kind of atrocities how do we
see differences or similarities to those
pastimes today in these free democratic
kind of free speech driven societies
that we supposedly live in
so our task in my view is to focus in on
the problem as clearly as we can so the
problem in a sense is
everything we can think about and say
should it be aired publicly like what
are the costs and benefits in some sense
of free speech what does it mean to
speak freely are there times where it's
better just to stay silent because you
have a truth that's dangerous
now today that is considered an
offensive idea that there are some
things that are true
that should not necessarily be
publicized
you know because there's this notion
that oh look the superiors are lying to
us because they think that we're the
plebs who can't handle the truth and so
they're concealing something from us and
if only you know they hadn't done that
then we could have made the decision for
ourselves
that's a natural democratic sentiment
it's probably correct so far as it goes
but the interesting cases are where you
know there's an argument on the other
side so i'll give you a classic example
here again plato's republic a go-to
source for these kinds of issues and
really we're dealing right with the
first part of the book
socrates is talking to a character about
he's getting the other characters
getting old he's about to die socrates
is asking him you know what have you
learned from uh getting old and what are
you worried about that kind of thing the
question comes up about
justice
being
paying back your debts to people
returning what you owe
so socrates asks this character he says
imagine your friend gave you
his weapon
and now he wants it back
but he's out of his mind and you know
that if you give him his weapon he's
gonna go commit some atrocity with it
and he asks you do you have it
wouldn't it be just to lie to him and
say that you don't
and even though it's his it's his
property so you might say like according
to a property rights argument you should
give it to him wouldn't it be more just
not to
so aren't there limitations on telling
the truth and on property rights when it
comes to justice depending on the state
of mind of the person who's making the
claim
so the other character he's like yeah
you know that sounds it sounds right
like i probably would lie about it and
wouldn't give it back
and then he goes off to do something
else but we're left to think about it
are there times where it's just to lie
or
is it always just to tell the truth
another way of putting it if we're
committed to free speech and truth
telling are we sacrificing some
important political considerations
the important thing is not necessarily
what we think about that right away but
the fact that it's such a crucial
inquiry and therefore that we need to
look at these sources to get our heads
straight around it
i know again democrats
and we're in this sense we're all
democrats i don't mean the democratic
party i mean people who grew up in
liberal democracies don't like that idea
and yet
if people as brilliant as plato and
aristotle had a defense of it we should
probably consider their arguments so
when we look at this what it requires is
a level of critical thinking that
doesn't seem to be taught in schools and
what i find so fascinating about you is
that you
appear to be a very serious critical
thinker
you are able to separate out
different components and different ideas
from a single individual so you don't
seem to label someone as good or bad or
because they are associated with one
movement or another that all of their
ideas must be good or bad
and that has led to a very interesting
situation where you've essentially been
blackballed by traditional academia
university systems
and all of that can you tell us a little
bit about that journey and that path and
kind of how you got to a point where you
essentially were forced to either give
up the craft that you had been so
interested in
or kind of strike it on your own go
direct to students and say i don't need
the university and the credentialism
that they provide in order to actually
carry out what i'm interested in
that's right i was effectively
blacklisted from academia during my phd
program because i worked on a thinker
named alexander dugan i don't want to
assume that anybody's heard of him he's
been called putin's brain putin's
rasputin the most dangerous philosopher
in the world and a bunch of other things
and i gave an interview based on my
research at the time where i said look
there's a lot that we can learn from him
there's a lot that's good about him
there's a lot that i like about the
substance of his teaching which in short
opposes
totalitarian liberal globalism it says
there's more to being human than being a
liberal and on that premise he develops
this account of politics geopolitics
international relations philosophy and
so on
well my professors at the time didn't
like that they thought it was
apologetics for neo-fascism for a
genocidal maniac as they see him
and it's no surprise everybody has heard
stories today of cancellations i went
through my version of it but here's the
thing
when you have something that is deeply
important and interesting to you
in my case it was what's the
relationship between politics
and
philosophy whether we think man has a
soul or not whether we think the world
is created or not whether you think time
is cyclical or linear let's call that
philosophy how does that relate to our
opinions about political things that's
the question i was in effect studying so
if you have a question that's so
important to you you just go to the end
of it and there will be obstacles that
arise along the way opposition and
sometimes it could be not opposition
maybe for example there's fanatical
support and that becomes its own kind of
temptation but you need to stick to the
straight and narrow path of the question
you're pursuing which is what i tried to
do but yeah i was blacklisted it was a
pretty brutal experience as far as
academic politics goes but the great
thing is that i was able to open my own
school after the fact go directly to
students as you said microphone camera
lecture notes and suddenly you know the
world is your oyster and i think it's a
sign that a lot of the traditional
institutions including university
they're experiencing some hard times
because they're enforcing
ideology instead of encouraging thinking
and so students and their parents and
people who are professionals are looking
for genuine alternatives where do we go
if we don't just want to be lectured
about race and gender
where do we go if we don't just want to
be told that whites are guilty of
oppressing everybody around the world
where do you want to go if you actually
want to read the classics so in higher
education today there's a kind of war on
the classics because if they taught that
there's beauty if they taught that
there's excellence and if they thought
that there's truth in some sense they're
all enemies of global liberalism because
global liberalism wants to tell you
don't think about truth don't think
about beauty don't think about that kind
of thing
so it's been a blessing it was a
blessing in disguise at the time i only
felt the brunt of it but it's proven to
be a real blessing because i now have
students all over the world and we just
get to discuss the greatest books ever
written and think about them clearly and
help them illuminate our understanding
of today's world uh but yeah the
cancellation is something that students
if you're listening to this and you are
drawn to quote unquote controversial
thinkers uh you know some of them you've
had on this show
you have to wait for yourselves you know
because you could get kicked out of your
job you could get kicked out of your
school and you could be branded as so
many people are being branded today a
semi-fascist a total fascist the
neo-fascist
and the biggest concern in my personal
opinion is that it's a few steps from
calling someone a fascist to saying all
fascists should be eradicated to you
know jailing or killing your political
opponents and it's not so far-fetched
the
guy that i work on alexander dugan one
of many thinkers but probably the one
i'm best known for
his daughter was killed not long ago in
russia in the act of political terrorism
so these things happen uh right now they
don't happen very much in north america
hopefully they never do but you know
there was an attack on salman rushdie
and uh
it's
it's a stone's throw from calling
someone a fascist to saying that they
should be
uh imprisoned or attacked
so
one of the most straight and narrow is
we need to think we need to think we
need to think that's it there's no no
threat should snuff out our desire to
think about these issues carefully one
of the things that's so fascinating to
me uh kind of about the line of your
work is uh these are ideas this is
thinking this is literally reading books
reading the ideas that other people have
put forward and contemplating them
critiquing them and also figuring out
where do you
agree where do you disagree uh where do
they get things right where do they get
things wrong and what is fascinating to
me about that kind of attrition if you
will of analysis is that every single
student who went to any level of
education in a democratic developed
nation uh probably thought about some
individual their ideas their writings uh
and kind of their work and it was put
through some degree of critique now
sometimes that was very elementary
sometimes it was very very uh kind of
sophisticated but when
most people and maybe most is an
exaggeration maybe it's many people in
the western world first heard of dugan
especially in recent times it was around
uh this political act of uh terror and
so the headlines read uh you know
russian uh name your descriptor whatever
kind of adjective they wanted to use uh
or noun and they said uh his daughter
was killed and a lot of people said wow
that's crazy they read the headline and
they kind of moved in on
what i saw on twitter which was
fascinating was a
heavy degree of controversy between
this person is a good person this person
is a bad person and i didn't know
anything about them and so i started to
go and google a little bit more i came
across some of your work and the book
that you wrote can you tell us a little
bit about this individual and and maybe
do so calling out along the way uh what
are the critiques of him and then what
are the things that uh maybe you've
separated away from those critiques and
say hey actually i think that these are
the ideas that that are interesting or
worth kind of uh spending more time on
sure so alexander dugan is a russian
political philosopher ideologue and
activist so it's important to understand
that he combines several roles in
himself that often are parceled out
among other people so you could be very
fascinated by him as a philosopher and
repelled by some of his activism that
would be consistent because it's all
contained in one person he started his
intellectual activity so far as i can
tell in the 80s in the ussr where he was
looking into
figures who we know as traditionalists
that's rene guenong julius evola as well
as all kinds of movements of thought
that are
weird for us or that we're not used to
thinking about like hermeticism
gnosticism mysticism occultism and stuff
like that
at the collapse of the soviet union
you had the onset of american liberal
dominance geopolitically and
ideologically and intellectually dugan
rebelled entirely with all of his
forces and they're quite powerful with
his writing and thinking he rebelled
against the dominance of american
liberalism and he began to develop a
political theory that drew on all of the
intellectual resources
available past and present that could
oppose
global liberalism
it was like a grab bag to a certain
extent some of the sources carl schmidt
martin heidegger young even you know
jung
sources from psychoanalysis from
geopolitics and he put together a model
that reasoned as follows
in the 20th century there was a war
between liberalism communism and fascism
fascism was defeated you had the cold
war a bipolar world ussr usa
that came to an end you had the unipolar
world and if you want to oppose american
global dominance you can no longer do so
on the basis of the old political
theories so he opposes the fascist
response to liberalism he opposes the
communist response to liberalism their
time is gone it's time for something new
and that's something new he declared as
the fourth political theory he said
people are so used to thinking in terms
of liberalism communism and fascism
which i think is true if you look around
you'll see they still do it if you're
not a liberal and you're not on the left
you're a fascist okay that's the way
people think
well he said let's declare the space of
something called the fourth political
theory and he developed it over a series
of books
the reason why he's
so toxic there are a few reasons why one
is that in opposing global liberalism he
met with many of america's enemies many
people who don't like america many
anti-liberals who aren't communists
therefore you know he had in his circle
people who maybe are in their own way
neo-nazis or fascists
uh so he wanted to have under his
umbrella all kinds of tactical alliances
even if theoretically he was developing
something else
pro-ukrainians
don't like him because he has said
things against ukrainian statehood that
they can't get on board with so he
doesn't think that ukraine should
continue to exist in its current state
form he's not against ukrainian
ethnicity or ukrainian people but he
doesn't like the ukrainian political
project and he thinks that that should
be uh undone
so there are
those kinds of reasons why people find
him obnoxious
if he's anti-american and you're
pro-american that's one reason if he's
anti-liberal and you're pro-liberal
that's another reason so
all of those kinds of things are in a
sense understandable but now we go to
the opposite side and we say well look
there are some very pro-american
american people in america who also
don't like globalism who also don't like
totalitarian liberalism who are also
tired of woke culture cancellation
who also don't think that america should
be the world's police officer
and so what do they do when they're
trying to understand their own situation
well in my view it makes sense to
look at intelligent people who have
articulated an alternative and then we
can sort of pick and choose work our way
through it that kind of thing
so
the parts about dugan's thought that i
like the most
i would say
his use of
okay i
like philosophical supremacists people
for whom philosophy is the most
important human activity they have a
special place in my world okay
he's a philosophical supremacist so i
pay close attention when he talks about
the relation between philosophy and
politics he says we should take
seriously the beginning and end of
western philosophy as we try to think
through our situation the beginning
that's plato the end that's heidegger so
for dugan plato and heidegger are
crucial thinkers for understanding
politics i would say that's indisputable
there's no way you could
ignore that kind of argument i like
about dugan that he's got a
comprehensive attitude towards politics
and society he studies many disciplines
and he gives us a way of thinking about
them without the ideological blinders of
liberalism
what i don't like yeah i don't like some
of the
cheap propaganda shots i don't like it
when a lot of his arguments you can
almost tell at the outset
that they're all going to end up in a
certain place
you know so there are times where he's
limited by his own dogma
there are times when he's limited by his
own ideology and his geopolitical
commitments like a mirror image
of western thinkers
the only thing is that on balance in my
view he's freer than most western
thinkers western thinkers are totally
trapped in their ideological situation
and he has some
you know he's outside of it crafting it
shaping it thinking about it
and that's why i think he's valuable for
us but yeah he's
not uncontroversial either on a purely
philosophical level or all the more so
on a political level and is this kind of
anti-liberalism or anti-american stance
uh the reason why he's considered the
most dangerous philosopher in the world
or are there other things
it's not just that he's anti-liberal
it's in a sense that he has the energy
of his activism behind his
anti-liberalism so he's not just a
thinker i mean he is a thinker it's not
just a thinker so he when he's active
politically when he's organizing or
doing outreach or something like that
it can seem like
i'll put it this way
russia
is a ideological
opponent of the united states and dugan
is the most comprehensive russian
ideologue ideologist so he's dangerous
in the sense that he's providing a
worldview alternative to the dominant
one and he's not just some
body with no
possible political power behind him he's
a thinker in a country that could
actually
help to shape a multi-polar world you
know so it's a combination of these
kinds of factors like if he was just a
guy on an island somewhere writing these
books it may have been considered less
dangerous
than if he's somebody whose ideas are
percolating through the russian policy
establishment directly or indirectly
and is that why he would be considered
putin's brain is that many of these
ideas get filtered through
and potentially end up getting
implemented or at least helping shape
some of the thought processes and
actions of the russian government or how
do you look at the relationship between
maybe dugan's ideas and then some of the
actions taken by that specific kind of
government organization
i'll tell you how i see it because
there's a dispute among people who watch
dugan and putin and they say they've
never met there's no sign of a direct
relationship but here's the way that i
would characterize it
whenever russia acts
as a distinct civilization
not part of the western world not part
of the european world but in opposition
to them or at least on their own path
they're going to need a set of ideas to
understand themselves and to justify and
elaborate their policies
and those will be dugan's ideas to a
large extent whether they go through
directly or indirectly whether they get
mediated through other parties and think
tanks or whatever the case might be
because it's like dugan has been
developing this conceptual system for 30
years or however many
and
he's now
seeded the cloud of ideas so that as
soon as you turn on your mind and start
to wonder what is russia if it's not a
european country what is russia if it's
not part of the west
doogan's concepts will come raining down
you may not know where they came from
but when they land
that's what's going on so that's my view
you know he's sort of like the
behind the scenes mastermind of russia's
civilizational path
he's not the only person in russia
thinking about these things
but it kind of follows in a strange way
from the nature of genuine philosophical
thought that you don't have to be in the
spotlight to be relevant or influential
in some sense the more profound thinker
you are as a hidden philosopher the less
easy it is to see the real nature of
your influence but the more that
influence is actually operative over
time so i put dugan kind of in that
light
when we try to read if you read putin's
speeches
february 24th speech and whenever he
declares a multipolar world wherever
he's speaking out against american union
polarity wherever he's talking about
russian values and the degradation of
values in the west and you wanted to
know where is the most
fully formed version of that worldview
i would suggest it's worthwhile to look
to dugan as that
and when we begin to understand you
mentioned earlier there's been these
kind of three specific categories of
political thought there's liberal
there's communist and there's fascists
what is this fourth one does it have a
name to it has he gone as far as to
kind of completely construct it or is it
more so just hey there's something else
and it yet isn't fully formed
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep good sleep is a game changer and
the eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine i sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod three you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
innate sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pomp today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order
aidsleep.com not only do i sleep on it
every night it literally changed my life
and i begged the founders to let me
invest in the company 8sleep.com
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep
it's experimental still so it's not
fully formed but it's not
merely a rejection of the first three
so he starts his argument that way he
says the fourth political fear is
neither liberal nor communist nor
fascist and the next step for example is
as follows says well liberalism thinks
in terms of the individual
communism thinks in terms of the class
fascism thinks in terms of the state as
a matter of fact and nazism thinks in
terms of the race
so nazism and fascism for him are the
two parts of the third political theory
so he says the fourth political theory
is going to be neither individualistic
nor class based nor racist nor statist
first and foremost it's going to be
something else
then we raise the question what's it
going to be
and here he has a kind of obscure answer
and a kind of clear answer the obscure
answer is that
well
ultimately the obscure answer is the
philosophy of martin heidegger which
talks about human existence using a kind
of unfamiliar jargon dassein is a key
word for heidegger dugan says we're
going to construct the fourth political
theory on the basis of the view that
dassen is the key player
not the individual not the race not the
state not the class so again that's kind
of obscure because it requires some
familiarity with heidegger but on the
other side he says
the actor of the fourth political theory
is the in russian narod
reason i have to say it in russian
before english is because in english
it's the people
but people for us usually means it can
mean like a collection of individuals
like a lot of people met in the park
today but it can also mean like people
in the sense of peoples
with the sort of ethnic dimension
and so dugan says
this idea of people like peoplehood is a
powerful
pillar
of our thinking about politics and so he
has a book on that called
ethno-sociology and he's developed that
idea in different places like what's the
relationship between people and state
people and civilization
people and morality
but again people in this very specific
sense
uh you should understand as well he has
like 50 or so books okay they're
probably not all brilliant and i haven't
read all of them but they develop these
intuitions and insights in to various
directions so that you know
geopolitically the fourth political
theory implies a multi-polar world of
many civilizations
in the realm of education the fourth
political theory implies that there's
going to be an alternative to the study
of economics and law which he sees are
the two most important disciplines for
liberalism and so on different
authorities different approaches
different texts that kind of thing
uh what's missing in a sense there's no
like what we would expect from a
political theory could be well what's
your system of constitutional law how do
you apportion a rights between uh
citizens and what's your doctrine of uh
economics for example that's not where
he focuses his attention he focuses it
on more you could say foundational
questions
more of the ideological side
how do you justify
an alternative to individualism
for example you know what should we be
thinking about when we think about
destiny or history or purpose or meaning
for a political community you see it's
different there from just economics
when you think about
dugan he seems to be on one very far
into the extreme based on let's just
call it kind of the uh the central
conversation that's occurring there's
positives and negatives which i think
you've done a great job outlining on the
other end of the extreme maybe the
western world view kind of liberal
philosopher
or
a political thinker
what i'm very interested in is on the
surface they look very different they
look on opposite ends of the extreme
they look at a uni unipolar world versus
a multi-polar world they look at u.s
dominance versus
a non-u.s dominant world
but it also appears that there's lots of
similarities between these extremes one
you already mentioned which is that
these thinkers are both
at ends of the extreme but they are held
hostage by their ideologies and maybe
even their geopolitical uh um kind of
alliances or allegiance uh also they're
just pure geography as to where they
live how they grew up the society in
which they operate in the need to be
accepted in those societies things like
that
how do you look at similarities right
other than just being held hostage by
the ideology to some degree are there
other similarities that you can point to
and say listen the western philosopher
the western political thinker uh is
exactly the same as a dugan uh in
certain ways
yes so
you could say that
people are trying to defend
their side
you know there's a kind of mirror image
here so for dugan it's important that
he's developing a russian political
theory
that helps russia establish its
civilizational sovereignty
in a world that is seemingly dedicated
to eradicating russian identity
and you know there are similar projects
among western intellectual circles
depending on what identity people have
so we need to defend our gender identity
or our racial identity or our republican
identity or whatever the case is
the parallelism is in some sense the
love of one's own
and the
vigorous defense of one's own the
difference is what you consider your own
so that's the main similarity i would
say
people know
in these circles that ideas somehow
matter they legitimate certain policies
they make other policies possible so one
similarity is that you know the
importance of ideas and that you want to
put the ideas in the service to a
certain extent of these political
loyalties and political identities
now that's
par for the course in a way because when
it comes to education there's always
been the understanding
that one way you could educate is by
taking a
political or theological principle or
dogma and saying what kind of education
would help this dogma you know so
catholic education conservative soviet
liberal doesn't matter the point is in
all of these cases the education is in
the service of the ideology so that's
another similarity when things get
really interesting is when you turn it
in the opposite direction you say well
what if we begin to philosophize about
our dogmas about our identity about our
first principles maybe they're not as
compelling as we thought they were you
know so
that's
the way these things shake out
people like to defend their side and
they can be very creative in the defense
of their side with all of these authors
and thinkers that's not necessarily the
same as critical thinking that's still
just the very elaborate defense of your
team
obviously on a geopolitical scale what
we've seen over the last couple of
months and maybe even you know two or
three years
in the immediate analysis is somewhat of
a backtracking from the globalism and so
if you think of uh the pull-out in
afghanistan if you think about russia's
invasion of ukraine and the u.s and
nato's refusal to directly participate
if you think about the potential
conflict between china and taiwan if you
think about supply chains and
manufacturing trying to be reshored
within the united states after
the covet 19 pandemic like there's all
these little data points that on the
face each individual one doesn't seem
super super important it definitely is
noteworthy it makes headlines uh but it
doesn't tell the full story but when you
then add them up it does feel like
there's a shift from a pure
globalization is good to now maybe
nationalism is good to some degree
how do you think about uh
through the lens of so many different
philosophers and and the learning of
history about this shift from
potentially a globalism uh kind of
pursuit to something that is more
nationalistic and maybe not so uh
interested in the integration on a
global scale
well you're right that there are these
several events taking place we'll
probably see more of them and in some
way that's the fault line the globalists
want to make sure that all of those
conflicts are resolved in the direction
of a stable globalist world and other
people want to exploit them to have the
alternative take shape well this too is
an old problem just think about the
tower of babel can we have a unified
humanity is that desirable is it
possible or is it necessary to have
humankind scattered
into multiple communities speaking
multiple languages
so as we're recording this there's a
national conservatism conference taking
place organized by joram hassoni who
defends a world order of nations and who
opposes uh globalist agenda and there is
a competition now i would say in the
intellectual space of alternatives that
may not be strictly nationalistic they
could be something else including dugans
dugan this is weird for people because
we don't have all the distinctions we
need to think clearly about this but
dugan is not a
nationalist in a
sense and in fact russian nationalists
often don't like him he's more of an
imperialist and he tends to defend large
spaces of a multi-ethnic or
multinational kind
but not all the way to global so these
we're like in a
situation where errors are ending and
there's this uh ferment about what will
come next and it's another reason why
it's so important to study it creative
thinkers okay to study people who are
articulating all
alternatives what will come next what
should come next what might it look like
so i'll give you an argument you know
one is that a globalist world is not
possible because there's always going to
be some spirited desire to have the
dignity and honor of your particular
community better represented you know
somehow to become part of the globalist
world there's a lot that you have to
give up and not everybody's so ready to
give up things that they hold dear so
you know if you're going to defend the
things you hold dear that's like
trying to puncture the shield or you
know the front of the globalist world so
that's just a simple psychological fact
of the human soul you know we're not
willing to suppress our desire for honor
and there's a loss of honor somehow in
becoming part of the globalist world
this is both an old question as i say
with the tower of babel example and one
where we have to find new solutions to
it you know dugan's model many
civilizations uh joram hazoni's model
national traditions nations nation
states that's what we have to stick to
other people may have some other
alternative but what i think everybody
can sense
is that the order of world affairs is in
the process of being renegotiated
from a bipolar world to a unipolar world
to now we have a question mark if russia
gets
how could you put it if russia is not
successful in its war or in its special
military operation if it's not
successful in asserting its state
sovereignty and civilizational
sovereignty that's a setback from the
point of view of opposition to globalism
and that's a big win for the supporters
of globalism so all of the things that
are happening geopolitically they have
this ideological moral theoretical
philosophical dimension and it's it's in
the air right now because there's been
no decisive blow you know you could say
that trump's victory was a kind of
anti-globalist moment biden's victory
was a one you know put one back into the
globalist side but now with all of these
conflicts that you mentioned we don't
know yet the final state of affairs but
a lot's at stake more than just oh you
know the totalitarian country lost and
the democratic country won or vice versa
the
world view behind the scenes that's at
stake in all of these battles is a
little bit deeper and more complex than
that from the point of view of the
globalists it's pretty simple it's
totalitarian states versus dictatorships
uh the open society versus its enemies
but you know if we look from the side
do we have to consider the alternative
how do other players uh kind of enter
into the phrase so if you take the
united states obviously stands for
something very specific uh and has kind
of implemented their view
of how societies democracies capitalism
should operate and done so with great
success uh around the world in many
areas if you look at somebody like
russia
and kind of their actions in ukraine and
then more so just the political
philosophy that they seem to be
embodying and kind of even openly
talking about
this multipolar world
it looks like it's a okay there's two
different sides to this debate this
battle this conflict this clash of ideas
but then there's things like china or
india or the entire continent of africa
uh or even south and central america and
so how does some of those places and
ideologies and
kind of you know billions of people who
live there play into
what appears to be a simple kind of
clash of ideas that maybe isn't so
simple
yeah i don't have a great answer except
to say this
you had the moment of american global
domination and if you're somebody in
another country not russia not the
united states let's say not china if
you're in india or you're in south
africa or wherever you happen to be
you're faced with the question
what do we do we can
sort of merge into the global unipolar
world giving up our interests to a
certain extent giving up some of our
values our traditions and
doing whatever we need to do to protect
ourselves under the new circumstances
making friends with the right people and
becoming enemies to the right people
that kind of thing but there needs to be
some system of self-understanding
america has a system of
self-understanding i've just been
mentioning that russia has one
particularly as elaborated by dugan but
not only so the question is in these
other countries do they have some native
traditional resources to draw on that
would help them oppose if they want to
the new situation at the level of ideas
because again we have to interpret what
we're doing in the world we need some
system of self-understanding so one of
the things that i think is important
about dugan's model
personally is that it is in a way
exportable to other countries
so
when it is applied specifically to
russia it takes on a specifically
russian character but the general idea
of a fourth political theory as he's
developed it throughout these books it
can take on a specifically indian
character it can take on a specifically
brazilian character and chinese and so
on so i think that as an ideological
export in a way dugan's fourth political
theory has proven to be a resource for
countries
other than
russia who are looking to find their
place in this world separately from what
the united states sees for them
so for example dugan definitely has
interested readers and followers in iran
where he meets as he said before with
some of their uh crucial figures and
discusses the application of heidegger's
ideas to iranian civilizational identity
these aren't things we normally think
about but they're important to see as
background processes that are helping to
build a kind of international
anti-liberal front
not just on the basis of some
reactionary anti-americanism like we
used to worry you know we just marked
september 11th a few days ago we used to
worry about islamism as a threat but
somehow that was narrowly constrained to
certain islamic radical sects
but now you have a broader theoretical
umbrella that's not just pinned to a
single religion
and that has these serious philosophical
pillars so it's a it's a new kind of
challenge i would say but
that's how i think about those other
countries and if you look to see who's
supporting russia or at least who's not
voting against it at the u.n
general assembly that kind of thing
you'll see you could say roughly you
have the west and the rest and this rest
category this rest
they look to
russia in a way and they want russia to
be successful in a way because under the
umbrella of the political victories and
under the umbrella of the ideological
model they can start to feel like they
are civilizationally sovereign or at
least not just under the thumb of the
globalists may not work out that way
there's no guarantee
but that's the idea
when you begin to think of these periods
of transition uh where you know we lived
in a
kind of multi-polar world or or whatever
you want to call it we went to this kind
of united polar world and now there's
this question mark that you described
and there's people pulling at two
different you know kind of outcomes
institutions seem to be a pretty
interesting uh kind of aspect or a
detail here and institutions can be
national institutions uh they can be
made up specifically for the protection
of individuals if you look somewhere in
like the united states uh and then
there's these global institutions if you
think of the world bank or uh the world
economic forum or these types of
organizations uh even nato to some
degree
being a a kind of more globalistic uh
institution
there's a lot of folks i think in the
west who would agree that institutions
are degrading maybe in the most
watered-down version or full-on
collapsing in the most extreme version
sometimes the conversation makes people
uneasy so rather than talk about
governments or or kind of collections of
countries they prefer to point to
mainstream media organizations or higher
education institutions those seem to be
a little bit less taboo to kind of
discuss as part of this like
institutional collapse
how do you see institutions and their
role and kind of their ability to
survive these transition periods
regardless of whether we end up on
either end of the spectrum
institutions
have
okay classical political philosophers
put it like this in a sense you can't
expect the institution to do the work
that character building would normally
do for you now maybe you have
institutions that build character but
you can't just rely on the institution
to solve the problems and ignore
who's in the institution how they're
formed it's kind of like you know i have
a building on the street but which kind
of shop is in the building is going to
make a difference you know so you have
these various institutions but what's
the moral and intellectual training of
the people in them how have they been
formed to see the world and to
understand themselves
so
there was a time where it's kind of like
policy makers kicked the can from moral
training to just relying on the
institutions and their rational
processes to make sure everything works
out smoothly and efficiently and that
sort of
you could say uh removal of the question
of the education of character
it's we see it in a way
the institutions that i know best and
think about in this relation are the
universities
and the regime type you could say so
classically a regime was the set of
institutions that you could say are
responsible for the ruling of the
country but here's the key thing
each of those
looks up to some ideal so for example
you might look up to the ideal of
freedom you might look up to the ideal
of honor you might look up to the ideal
of wisdom and depending on where you
look the institutions will operate
differently they'll place their emphasis
differently so i think that some of our
institutions of education are looking up
to equity diversity and inclusion
and in doing so they're looking away
from
beauty
wisdom truth
insight and those kinds of things
so
when you ask about institutions that's
always where my mind goes you have to
see what are they aiming at where are
they looking to and wherever we see a
sort of misfunction or a dysfunction it
could be in the institutional design but
sort of the
more interesting place to look from my
point of view is the
intentions and aims
educationally you know
this is a big question
why should every discipline
in the university be first and foremost
concerned with diversity inclusion and
equity
that seems strange
are there no other goals of an education
than that that just shows you the
ideologization of the university
so that's always and again this is
really what the political philosophers
teach us they teach us look to the ends
look to the principles whether they're
the first principles of our thinking or
the ends of our action that's sort of
what determines where we're going why we
see something and don't see something
else
one of the ideas that i find
interesting and worth considering
is this idea of diversity inclusion
equity
or kind of in a more simplistic manner
uh that the conversation around race and
uh how that impacts uh various things in
our society
is is it possible to analyze race
without being racist and what i mean by
that is is the introduction of the idea
inherently now you are putting people
into buckets and once you put people
into buckets it's kind of human nature
like we aren't as smart as we think we
are and as we meddle in things sometimes
we actually create worse problems than
what the original problem was
and what that would hold constant is if
that is true
then the people who are attempting to
address a problem that they have
identified uh they're well intentioned
they're they're good nature they're
trying to do the right thing
and it's less about
these individuals are wrong or uh that
they are doing something uh that is
nefarious and more so just it is human
nature it's a story as old as time where
when humans meddle into free markets
they end up actually uh causing issues
with that intervention
we can't help but think and so it's not
in a sense a question if you're going to
think from the point of view of race or
think from the point of view of class or
look at the latest speeches from the
democratic party thinking in terms of
fascism and labeling all of their
opponents fascists also putting them in
a bucket
what's worse to label half the country
fascist or to think carefully about
these other controversial issues so in
some sense if you're in the political
arena or you're outside of it but
thinking about politics no matter what
concepts you're employing there's going
to be controversy politics is not
something that you can just think about
without there being some dividing lines
without it feeling like someone's
getting characterized and cataloged and
put into a bucket what we need to do
when we practice our thinking is be
cognizant of that fact and make sure
that we're not having a slippage from
trying to solve a problem to creating
new problems just like you said with
market intervention so that is a
challenge like you don't want either
extreme there what are you going to just
stop thinking about how to solve
problems in politics because it can
create new problems no that's not
feasible we're going to leave everything
exactly the way it is that's not
feasible so it's a process of feedback
and
modification in other words no you're
not a racist if you include racial
considerations in your thinking unless
those racial considerations are like you
know white people shouldn't do this
black people shouldn't do this and other
races shouldn't do or should do
something else
the task is to think carefully similarly
with the semi-fascism alt-right and
stuff like that are there no
domestic terrorists in the united states
no prob you know that's probably too
extreme are there no like actual
neo-fascists no there probably are some
does that mean we should label everybody
who supports trump's agenda or everybody
who opposes biden's agenda a fascist or
a neo-nazi or something like that no
so
the whole task whether we're thinking
about politics or something else
is to learn to fine-tune our thinking
there are so many pitfalls
just like we said ideologically you know
one pitfall is to come to hate your own
country you fall so in love with some
other country that you like turn your
back on your own another one is to love
your country so much that you don't see
its flaws or you can't think about its
limitations
so
these are exercises and that's one of
the things that philosophy helps us to
do it's one of the reasons why we study
old books like plato's and aristotle's
and new books you know like nietzsche
and heidegger leo strauss carl schmidt
it's one of the reasons we need to
train our thinking like you know people
go and they do brazilian jiu jitsu or
they do whatever they do and in your
first class you're probably getting
completely wrecked and maybe 20 years
later you're still getting wrecked but
you have to practice why should it be
any different in drawing political
distinctions and thinking carefully our
mind also needs to go through a training
program it's also not going to get it
right on the first try but you know then
when you get into a street fight so to
speak okay intellectual street fight
here things go wrong quickly
so i hate i just have to say this to be
super clear
if a person has the genuine intention of
understanding a problem
and
in pursuit of that genuine intention
they think in terms of whatever it
happens to be race state nation class
okay destiny individual religion god
satan whatever
if you are trying to think a problem
through and that's your intention
then under
the right circumstances you should
completely be able to go with that and
any time we shut it down
we're just snuffing out the human soul
we're snuffing out the human spark
what's the point
if you're gonna do that what's the point
of even having
a republic a country a political
community if you're taking what's
essential to the human being and just
destroying it
one of the other distinctions that i
think gets lost is the difference
between thinking and talking
now
usually people today uh don't spend as
much time face to face talking as maybe
you would do in other countries even but
uh definitely in history a lot of the
talking gets done on twitter or via
email uh maybe even on a youtube video
or some other social media platform and
what's fascinating to me is when you're
thinking and again you're coming at it
from a genuine perspective of trying to
understand of trying to learn of trying
to critique and trying to advance your
own thought process and kind of mental
models
nuance is a core component to that and
in some ways the nuance is incentivized
you have to understand the nuance or
therefore you cannot be successful in
your pursuit
where nuance is discouraged is pretty
much on every social media platform and
so if we use twitter as kind of an
extreme example
you and i can sit here and we can talk
for hours and have a nuanced
conversation and i think a lot of folks
will say okay
there's things i agree with there's
things i disagree with there's open
questions that i still have
and there's new viewpoints or new mental
models that i take away from the
conversation
but if they go and they simply read a
single tweet of less than 280 characters
they may walk away and say i hate that
person or that person is a [ __ ] or that
person is a genius
and so talk a little bit about kind of
the medium
being the message if we borrow
that terminology and how the nuance gets
lost in today's conversation and this
idea of a republic in a free democratic
conversation
uh is being influenced maybe for better
maybe for worse by
the actual products that we use to
communicate these ideas with each other
today's episode is brought to you by ftx
us they're a safe regulated way to buy
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they've got
very cheap fees sometimes as much as 85
cheaper than their competitors there's
also no minimum fees there's no
withdrawal fees or any other hidden fees
ultimately ftx us is trying to make it
dead simple for you to buy bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they also now have
digital stock trading as well with no
transaction fees and no payment for
order flow all you have to do is go
download the ftx app today from the app
store and use code pop and you'll get
some money back every single time you
trade 10 or more again go download the
ftx app today use code pomp and every
time you trade 10 or more they'll go
ahead and they'll give you some crypto
back the more you trade the more you
earn download the ftx app today
it's a
crucial matter andrew tate when he did
his video i think it was on rumble he
explained his side of the story after
the mass cancellations he said exactly
what you just did that he can talk for
two three hours overcome objections
explain his position and express it but
if someone wants to take a 20-second
clip especially if it's something that
they believe they can build their
audience on or that they can monetize or
that they can
take all of the hate and direct it in a
way that helps them you know sell their
product or do whatever they want to do
then it's impossible in a way to stop
today because that's what people are
consuming tick tock clips and youtube
and facebook and all the rest of it so
that is getting in the way obviously of
long carefully reasoned discourse but
look it's not
only today's problem
so again classical political philosophy
i like to use it as an example because
we might see there what has stayed
constant the fact that there's a gap
between what we think
and how it's
taken when we express it isn't just
because of tick tock instagram facebook
and twitter the thing is you never know
whether your audience has the background
that they would need to understand has
the intention of understanding is
hostile at the outset
wants to learn so people who are looking
for enemies they can find them very
quickly and people who are looking for
insight it's a different you know they
may be listening to the same thing but
deriving something completely different
from it so in some sense it's a question
of the motivations of the listeners why
do people
listen to these conversations
they're looking for a cheap shot
twitter has made it easier but you could
do it before twitter you could do it in
a pamphlet you could do it with a
loudspeaker you could circulate rumors
to get somebody killed that's not
something that has started recently
that's a old part of the human story so
as somebody who's in education yeah an
online education as someone who works on
philosophy
my appeal in some sense is always to
people's
intention why are you listening to
something what are you trying to get out
of it
you know there are always going to be
people who are just looking for the
attack
and they have to be as it were
treated separately or dealt with
separately
and
we need to understand when we're giving
them red meat
and when not but even so you could
stitch together a person's speech as you
well know and make it say anything you
want it to say
so we just need to keep our eyes on the
prize we need to be focused education
learning understanding understanding the
alternatives when it comes to people who
are super hostile i don't know maybe
that's an example where you would say
look
should
hostile listeners
whose whole modus operandi is to take
little clips or to take falsely
constructed clips and use them to direct
hate mobs
maybe those people shouldn't be on those
platforms maybe there are basic rules of
engagement and if you don't follow them
you should be off i know people don't
like it when someone they follow gets
kicked off twitter i'm not a big fan
either i hope it doesn't happen to me
and to the people i follow but you know
is it so bad that a account
solely existing for that purpose gets
pulled off the platform
you know then you have to say
so it's all they're all of these
considerations truly and
some sense the technology is making it
much harder to reach the sweet spot of
like
listening
how do you listen when everything is
going so quickly when everything is so
polarized and when everything is so
heated
well
it's never been
a mass
occupation
learning has never been a mass
occupation critical thinking has never
been a mass occupation what has been is
instant reaction to red meat that just
riles you up so you're going to have to
deal with it with or without twitter
with or without tick tock but i wouldn't
say they're helping this brings me to a
conversation around
the stoics and i think that many people
in today's society look to the stoics
and they say wow it is amazing how they
could be so thoughtful how they could
control their emotions how they could
be a version of a human that i wish to
aspire to
as you've studied history you studied
philosophy and and i'm assuming the
stoics as well
what are some of the lessons that you've
taken away that you feel are most
applicable to today's modern society are
there certain things that stick out in
your mind as uh things that uh folks
could spend a little bit of time learn
and have a outsized impact in a positive
direction today
yeah at a most simple level
that the philosophical life is the
happiest life that's sort of a basic
claim for plato aristotle socrates the
stoics the philosophical life is the
happiest life everybody is after some
form of happiness you might think more
money will make you happier more power
more lovers
more fame and popularity whatever the
case might be but you also have some
sense that you know there are people
with a lot of money who aren't happy
people who are very famous who seem
miserable people who have as many lovers
as you could ever dream of and you know
they don't seem quite satisfied fully
so philosophy raises the claim that the
examined life
is not only worth living but is in some
sense the pleasant the most pleasant the
most just and the happiest life
so
that is i would say philosophy's major
claim
and it's the one that if you are trying
to find happiness
you should take seriously and they
defend it they present it and i think
for myself and for so many people who
have fallen in love with philosophy over
the course of our lives
it has proven itself to be
accurate you know you're happy when you
think about the fundamental questions
you find yourself less
desirous of things that don't bring you
satisfaction
it's i'll put it to uh put it to you
this way my first philosophy professor
who i i credit him a lot with giving me
this path forward when he was
introducing philosophy to us he said
that philosophy gives you a well-ordered
soul so that your reason your will and
your desire are working together you
reason about what is it good for me to
desire you desire the things that your
reason has shown you are good and your
will is acting in consonance with your
reason and desire it's like a harmonious
life
as kind of symphonic life as well in
that sense
that is the main takeaway and another
one i would add is that
questions that i think everybody raises
from time to time about the meaning of
life or about why good people suffer or
why bad people
seemingly seem to do well in the world
you know those kinds of elementary
questions
whether they're moral or existential
philosophers can it's not like those
questions have no answers it's not like
nobody has
given us a step forward into thinking
about them
philosophy of all disciplines you can
learn from religion needless to say from
literature obviously but philosophy i
think is underappreciated as an inquiry
that takes us into the heart of human
life
and in doing so brings us as i say
pleasure joy decency and uh insight
when you say that a philosopher's life
is kind of the happiest life one of the
things that begs
is the fundamental questions that i
think philosophy ultimately tries to
spend time contemplating uh analyzing
and getting answers to
are there right answers are there
individual single answers or is there an
ever you know kind of constant pursuit
and the pursuit in some way is the
answer itself like you can never get to
what is the purpose of life uh there is
no right or wrong answer there is no you
know multiple choice make sure you get
it right pass go and move on to the next
question but in some ways
the whole idea is that there isn't one
single answer or do i have that wrong
well
there's progress in understanding so you
could develop your understanding of a
question of an issue
but it's not the same as a clearly
correct answer in some other discipline
you know if somebody asks you the answer
to a mathematical equation that's pretty
straightforward if they ask you is it
raining outside or isn't it here and now
there's a pretty straightforward answer
to that but if someone begins to ask you
ask you what is the nature of human
thought what is time how does time
affect our categories of understanding
was the world created or has it always
existed what does it even mean to raise
questions like that they don't have the
same kind of correct answer as an
inquiry in these other places does but
as i say there is
a
sort of
progress in philosophy
where you step further and further into
understanding the issue that you care
about and that you're talking about and
thinking about
it may not culminate in a correct answer
that you could just distribute to
everybody in the same way
but somehow
all of the philosophers are thinking
at this level
that
the first task for people new to
philosophy is to just enter into that
world
you know you could say at the outset
why do we even want a correct answer
about some of these questions in other
words what would a correct answer look
like about the relationship of time and
morality whether time is circular or
linear say okay time is linear okay you
have a correct answer on the nature of
time have you even understood what time
is there's always some further question
so it's hard to convey
for people who aren't
doing it but one of the beautiful things
about progress and philosophy is
in other disciplines it's kind of like
progress goes forward
progress in philosophy it's like it goes
backwards
it goes to a more fundamental level
you're always getting closer and closer
to some
basis point as opposed to going further
and further along the development of a
set of answers
now
in some sense
so just paraphrase that very prosaically
no there aren't correct answers but
people can have the completely wrong
impression of that be like why would i
want to study something that doesn't
give me any answers i'm looking for
certainty why do i just want to be
around people who are raising questions
isn't that just like some sort of mental
masturbation it isn't
it isn't
there's a realm that you can enter into
more and more completely in the process
of asking these questions the questions
don't keep reality away from you
the question drives you further into the
heart of the matter but you sort of have
to do it to um to experience it
uh that's one thing i would say and then
another
pretty amazing it's like kind of like
this think about the five best movies
you've ever seen or your five favorite
songs or something where each of them
has a claim to be particularly
outstanding
and now if someone were to ask you well
you know which is which is the best
one or rank them or you know compare
them amongst themselves
they may each have a total right
to their claim
of greatness
in a way that's not commensurable with
the other ones and in a way that can't
be ranked
philosophical inquiry is also like that
it's not always the case that plato has
refuted parmenides or that aristotle has
refuted plato
refutation is not always the name of the
game in philosophy
at times it's just these great thinkers
who have staked the claim to our
attention
and it's like you know a beautiful song
that you can't compare to another one or
five beautiful
artistic expressions that aren't
reducible
when we think about
the work that you do on a daily basis
the art of learning immediately jumps to
mind
talk to me a little bit about how you
actually learn so much when you're
reading a book what does that look like
are you just reading through it are you
highlighting are you taking notes
how do you then explore some of these
ideas do you just get on google and kind
of google around and have 200 open tabs
do you go when you seek out one specific
source of information like how do you
actually learn so much about topics that
frankly are pretty ill-defined and uh
can take you in so many different
directions all at once
i was lucky early on in my development
because i was taught the way that i now
practice which is read primary sources
and read them carefully
if you rely on google if you rely on a
secondary source if somebody's telling
you what you should think or what plato
thought then there's a big risk that
something could go wrong so
i learned
my teachers taught me
if you want to know what plato thought
you have to read plato if you want to
know what aristotle thought you have to
read aristotle now
that's only one step because it's you
know why would i have a school if that's
the case i would just tell all my
students go read plato go read aristotle
the second piece of the puzzle that is
so helpful is to have a guide who has
also read that work for a long enough
time to understand how it relates to the
big conversation among the other
thinkers and who can walk you through it
help you see things that you wouldn't
necessarily see on your own so
the study of primary source materials
together with guidance
is
for me at any rate everything that i've
learned i've learned that way i don't
usually rely on google to learn
something fundamental about these
thinkers although don't get me wrong
there are good sources stanford
encyclopedia philosophy there are good
articles people do publish in academic
journals and in other kinds of journals
so you can learn in different ways
but the
lesson that i was taught early that
stuck with me
was that imagine you go to an intro
philosophy class and they tell you
plato's republic is a book about the
ideal state which some people think
plato's republic is a book about the
ideal state
and then you later learn well ideal
is not a platonic concept plato doesn't
have a notion of an ideal
that's something different from what
he's talking about and he definitely
doesn't have a notion of the state
because what he calls the paulus is not
what we call the state
so if i'm relying on a secondary
interpretation
a short form and someone tells me yeah
plato's republic's about the ideal state
i actually haven't learned anything
about what plato thinks
really
so there's a challenge because
what do we do when it comes to
translations for example now the school
of thought that i follow they paid a lot
of attention to this they're like a
translation of a greek or a latin or
arabic or hebrew book
it should be as literal as possible so
that if plato uses one word in the greek
it should always be translated as much
as possible one word in the english you
know so the translator could also be
getting in the way of your understanding
of the original book
so these kinds of ideas here you know we
don't want to take shortcuts we want to
understand plato or whoever it is that
we're reading as much as possible on
their own terms
that's what
informs my study of these books and i
think that's one of the reasons i have
had a kind of unique experience reading
dugan compared to a lot of people who
work on him you know they will just
google him read a wikipedia quick
throwaway you know that he said
something crazy once or whatever the
case might be and on that basis they'll
dismiss him but because of my training
you can't really make a judgment until
you've read as much as possible of the
original ideally in the original
language
thoughtfully carefully and precisely in
doing so that's when all of the riches
open up because you see there's more
going on there than could be dismissed
i do take there was a time where i
wouldn't write in my books because i
thought it was sacrilegious that time
has passed so i do now i underline i dog
here i don't do any highlighting but
it's uh it's very helpful whatever works
for you whatever works when you're
working through a book but
you want to see like
what's the argument how is this key term
operating how does something he said
here relate to something you said 20
pages ago it's not easy but it's worth
you know what that's worth doing is so
easy
everything that's worth doing takes a
little bit of practice and comes with a
lot of frustration along the way but the
reward is worth it that's why we do it
same i think with reading especially
reading the great books
so reading is obviously a core component
of this kind of art of learning but one
of the things that i personally find
incredibly valuable is the conversation
around the reading as well so i can go
and i can read the primary sources i can
go and i can even read maybe other
people's critiques or support for those
pieces but then having the ability to
converse and to challenge ideas to have
my ideas challenged somewhat this like
war of ideas ends up actually forging
much more powerful much more well
thought out better articulated ideas how
do you think about conversation and
the intersection if you will of like the
art of learning like what where does
that fit into your process
yeah conversation is crucial plato's
dialogues after all are conversations
plato doesn't write under his own name
he just gives us conversations usually
socrates and some other people but
sometimes without socrates and then the
great books themselves are a
conversation so plato is responding to
his predecessors aristotle's responding
to plato heidegger you know they're all
talking to each other across the ages in
their books so even just the reading is
still a conversation across the books
but yeah so i have a lot of people that
i have private zoom calls with i do
private tutoring i have seminars that i
lead when i was in graduate school in an
undergraduate school i had close friends
that we would discuss these topics with
it's nice because you have to be able to
restate at least the basic arguments so
that takes a little bit of practice and
then other people may have seen things
that you didn't see which is beautiful
and it's that back and forth that helps
bring things to light i mean that's what
the that's what socrates calls dialectic
dialectic means through speech through
logos through conversation sometimes
it's a conversation we have with
ourselves that's somehow thinking right
we raise objections in our own uh silent
uh mind in our soul so to speak but when
you can do it with somebody else another
beautiful thing about conversing
especially around in my view philosophy
but other topics as well with other
people is
it's a basis for a genuine friendship
because the community of people who are
assessing arguments about what's good
what's just what's beautiful what's
important how should we think about this
we're all directed towards
truth together and so there's a
community of inquiring minds that gets
formed in those conversations and in
those discussions which is really
satisfying i should say that this is
going to differ for different people
like i'm pretty introverted and not
particularly social as a rule so my
first inclination is not to put together
like a big study circle or a lot of
people to be talking others will find
that you know they need to have that in
order to be getting into the ideas to
remember them and to understand them but
i
personally am like you know the text
the teacher
also a book the conversation among the
books and then my students that i work
with and my friends that i talk to in
small circles
when you think about the school that you
created
some of it or many
would see that this was done out of
necessity after being blacklisted from
uh kind of the traditional
university system talk a little bit
about that process how did you think to
just go direct to
people how did you initially get it
started and where did you find the first
students
after i graduated with my phd i went to
work as a financial services copywriter
and i was doing private freelance
tutoring so i don't know if you could
tell i really love this topic i love to
talk about i love to teach it and i had
students who were working with me
privately
then i had somebody named justin murphy
he runs otherlife.com
invite me to teach under his rubric so
he was also bringing some exiled
academics under his umbrella to have
them teach courses for example on renee
gerard and on other thinkers he invited
me to teach a class on leo strauss leo
strauss is for me the gold standard
teacher of the history of political
philosophy he's a big part of what i do
and why i do it so i accepted i taught
this class on strauss and what i noticed
was that
teaching scales
when i was doing the private tutoring i
was putting a lot of time into preparing
for a single hour of one-on-one i mean i
might do five or six hours of prep for
fifty dollars of one-on-one time which
is what i was charging when i started
okay fifty dollars an hour
but i couldn't do an hour of tutoring
without really immersing myself in
everything i wanted to feel like i could
be extremely valuable and it just wasn't
sustainable so doing the course with
justin showed me oh i could put in the
same amount of work the same amount of
time have 40 50 people in a seminar
record it sell the recording scale the
teaching reach more people and make
better use of my time so that was such a
success that i turned my existing notes
on other courses that i had been
teaching privately into video courses
like this and uh it proved to be a
success people are really happy with the
materials and i'm glad to have them it's
been economically viable and uh that was
really how it got started you know i had
to continue teaching after the
blacklisting because i just can't stop
and uh it wasn't sustainable to do it it
scaled well
and it's proven to be
better than i thought in a way because
this was during covid in a way that i
started to scale and the universities
are taking a step in the wrong direction
as a rule a lot of professionals have
come to be my students people in tech
people in law people maybe close to
retirement who want to reconnect with an
original love for philosophy as well as
students who just aren't satisfied with
what's going on at the universities and
colleges so i think the timing was right
and uh i just consider it to be such a
fortunate opportunity to teach that way
outside of university because you know
it could have been like blacklisted
therefore no more opportunity to teach
thankfully i have more now than i ever
would have hoped for before
when you think about
what you are teaching now how is it
different than if you were a professor
at a university like we talked a little
bit earlier how some of these
universities are held hostage kind of by
wolf culture by censorship by the online
mobs uh are there specific differences
and things that you're able to teach now
that maybe wouldn't be possible if you
were inside of the legacy institutions
yeah it's not just the subject matter
it's everything about what i teach and
how i want to teach it so
i don't have to finish something in any
allotted time
you know i don't have just two hours a
week or just for
months a year or whatever the case is if
there's a book that requires a deep dive
then i can do a deep dive whether it's
video lectures supplemented with
seminars or some other format there's no
limitation
you could say the market is a limitation
but people who really want to learn
they're already willing to go to
whatever it is here that's required
another thing is that i have a couple of
courses on dugan i have a course on carl
schmidt who was a actual nazi but a
great legal thinker on leo strauss who
in some circles is considered to be too
reactionary
on heidegger you know and on other
figures who may be considered in many
departments just to right wing that's a
simplification but that's how they would
be seen in many departments
and here it's not
an issue
if somebody has something important to
say and i want to teach it i can do so
that's on the left as well by the way i
think jacques dereda is an author and a
teacher
worth studying
so that freedom pick my subjects pick
the way that i want to teach them what i
want to say about them nobody
hanging over my head telling me or my
students
what they are obligated to do or to hear
or to see or you know not to see and not
to hear
we decide
um
it's just liberating it's brilliant it's
a breath of fresh air not only for me as
an instructor but the students who take
the courses they tell me this is what we
would have wanted from a university or
this is what the universities once were
or you know we've been looking for this
type of thing everywhere but we couldn't
find it
incidentally too in a department of
political science let's say i may not
have been able to just propose a course
on bitcoin and art but if i want to have
a course on bitcoin and art in the
millerman school i can do that if i want
to have guest lecturers i can do that so
it's like
you know you're the master of the house
you decide and i'm always trying to
provide value for the students i'm
always trying to make sure that i'm
meeting a need that's there but
otherwise it's total freedom now i hope
it doesn't come to the point and i
certainly am not doing anything to
hasten this that the platform i'm on
tries to kick me off or you know that i
can no longer reach students or receive
payments
everything is very
decent there's no sort of ideological
indoctrination in this school and we're
not trying to be just controversial for
the sake of controversy as you can see
important thinkers important books
important questions that's the name of
the game so i don't see cancellation in
the cards here but you know there are
people who can no longer receive paypal
payments and who are kicked off other
kinds of processors and here maybe is
something where you know bitcoin and
other kinds of technologies like that
can also serve a place in the
educational
on new educational institutions moving
forward
what's fascinating to me about you and
your work is that you can
look at an individual take somebody on
the left and somebody on the right you
just described an individual who you
said was a literal nazi
yet you can separate out the
disqualification of some of their ideas
the distaste uh and the um in many ways
just malice or nefariousness of their
ideas
but not yet disqualify all of their
ideas and so it's in many cases in
society we try to put people in these
buckets good person bad person good
ideas bad ideas but what it seems like
you're able to do is you're able to
study an individual their writings their
teachings their thoughts all of the
content they've created the
conversations and interviews they've
done whatever
and then separate out and almost go idea
by idea or thought by thought and then
say i like these ideas these are ones i
agree with these are ones i find
interesting and i want to spend more
time on and then these other ideas or
things that are classified
in your view as uh negative or or
something you don't agree with or that
you don't want to spend more time on
why do you think you're able to do this
when so much of society
just labels at the surface level the
individual or at the
kind of collection of ideas they don't
have the ability to actually break down
the individual ideas and be able to
agree with some of the ideas of one
individual but also disagree with other
extreme ideas they may have
i'm not sure what the reason is for most
people but
in my case
my family's from the former soviet union
i think there's a kind of
autobiographical element to this
my dad's family is jewish my mom's
family is german
so i have like germans jews former
soviets
you know there's on one hand the german
intellectual tradition is full of
brilliant thinkers who are also you know
kind of like anti-semitic or not very
favorably disposed toward the jews and
the jewish tradition has many brilliant
thinkers who maybe aren't favorably
predisposed to other figures and then
there's the russian and i was born in
canada so there's like a sort of
politeness that allows me to be with all
of these different positions in the
first place
and my training you know so all of these
factors and influences together they
just produced this result i guess that i
don't
find it necessary
to shut down a thinker when you can see
that there's something there like i'm
not saying that you have to go out and
you know hug a nazi or something like
that we're not just talking about
anybody with a controversial opinion
here there are all kinds of knuckleheads
and much worse
but
what do you do when it comes to someone
who's obviously brilliant
what do you do when it comes to someone
you can clearly learn from
you know we all know the proverb of
throwing out the baby with the bathwater
so you have to decide in each case do
you want to do that or you know do you
want to raise the baby and see what
comes of it so to speak
you just learn with enough experience
that there are people who would like you
to throw out a thinker entirely
not because that thinker was a nazi
but because in studying them you'll
learn something that's dangerous
for these people's control over your
mind
they want to control what you think they
want to control how you feel and they
don't want to give you any outlet
any escape
and so it's very convenient to raise
this guilt by association charge against
people oh the only reason you're reading
heidegger is because he was a nazi you
must be one the only reason you're
reading schmidt is because you're a
neo-nazi or a semi-fascist
that's bogus that's manipulation that's
gaslighting in a big way so
separating it out
helps us to be free
now i know
people listening to this care about
their freedom well if everything is
getting collapsed you know the roof is
falling in on us and everywhere these
accusations of guilt by association and
fascist and nazi are affecting our
ability to move
we're just trapped under the rubble
there's no freedom in that we need to
separate things out we need to make
these distinctions and just find our
point of orientation so in that sense
it's a little bit of the autobiography
it's a little bit of the experience it's
i see i think it's seeing through the
way that these accusations are being
used to blind us
and to control us
and
you know it's philosophy philosophy
teaches you that you just have to be
patient with great ideas
doesn't necessarily mean you follow them
everywhere they lead but you don't even
know where they're going to lead until
you start looking at them carefully
i thought that we could wrap up with a
couple of rapid fire questions that i'd
be fascinated to hear uh your
perspective on or your answers
the first one is when you talk to
individuals are there one or two
questions that you ask them that help
you get at how they think what their
world view is or who they are as a
person
usually if i'm working with a student
who's just come to me i'll ask them
what's
what are you thinking about right now
like what thoughts are on your mind
right what questions are concerning you
what have you been reading lately
because
everybody has something present to them
you know they're worried about i have
one student who's really worried about
where things are going in education
somebody else is really worried about
masculinity the attack on masculinity
traditional masculinity what does it
mean to be a man
somebody else their primary concern is
with how do i be a believer how can i be
a believer today in a world that seems
to be attacking faith
so i like to ask people you know what
what's there for you now what are your
concerns and then that's where we start
what about your favorite book if you had
to answer the question you know i want
to learn more about philosophy where
should i start what would that answer be
so
the two major philosophers for me are
plato and heidegger they're difficult to
approach
if you're just starting but i would
recommend plato's republic or something
by plato just to get your feet wet even
if you don't understand it even if you
feel lost it could be
plato's apology which is where socrates
is speaking before the athenians in
defense of his life after they have
found him guilty of corrupting the youth
and sentenced them to death
plato and heidegger the beginning and
end of philosophy those are my sweet
spots although like i say you're not
gonna get it at first glance so here's
where i mention
all the credit
everything i've ever learned in
philosophy i want to give like 99 of the
credit to this guy named leo strauss so
one of the best ways to get an
introduction to the history of political
philosophy is by reading leo strauss
he's the one who taught a generation of
students that you should read the whole
book carefully he's the one who taught a
generation of students not to rely on
bad translations and he's the one who
showed that it's possible to think about
the old questions they're not irrelevant
anymore we don't just learn about plato
we learn from plato all of those kinds
of insights i owe to strauss and so
that's what i would recommend plato
heidegger and leo strauss
when
you think about your daily schedule
somebody who studies philosophy someone
who is familiar with the stoics uh
people may think that you just sit in
the dark all day and just think to
yourself and you're meditating and so
calm what does your daily schedule look
like in in reality
it doesn't look like that i have three
kids okay i have two boys and a girl i
work from home my kids just are uh in
the other room right now home from lunch
so it's always hectic it's always crazy
married 10 years uh in two days
so life is full it's very full it's not
empty i'm not on a mountain i'm not all
by myself and i'm not in the desert okay
uh
students business business partners
family friends kids it's everything it's
a full life
but you just learn to navigate that life
in a different sort of way
i read in the evenings i read in the
mornings i read the day i made my work
obviously my study as well so when i'm
doing work tutoring or teaching or
recording i'm also that's just lucky in
my case not everybody's going to be able
to do that
take your desire to read philosophy and
merge it with your work
but but that's what it looks like it
looks like a full life
family friends kids the whole shebang
and finding some time to read to write
to take classes to listen to people and
to uh think what about diet and sleep do
you do anything special there
no i don't think i would be a good role
model here in any way i sometimes i
sleep too much sometimes too little i
was a vegan for a long time now i'm not
so sure that's particularly healthy so
i have no advice about that everybody's
got to find what works for them i'm
surprised anybody could just eat steak
all day like jordan peterson does but i
guess that's good for some people
um
what can i say yeah i wouldn't take
myself as a role model here in any case
we got to get you a 8-sleep mattress
we've got these these mattresses uh a
company that i invested in and as they
sponsor the podcast they uh have like a
thermoregulated uh mattress so you can
make it super cold and uh hence the name
eight sleep get eight hours it's uh the
one thing i'm religious about now yeah
um my last question for you is kind of a
fun one do you believe in aliens you
think that there's life
off of earth
and is there anything in history or via
the study of philosophy that would
suggest uh kind of non-human life uh
that that we should consider
there's nothing in the philosophers that
i study and that i teach
on this topic although in my opinion
that shouldn't stop us from thinking
about it because if we're trying to
consider the meaning of human history
human life and the cosmos obviously
aliens are a relevant consideration so
except for that which is that i think
they have a place in our thinking i
don't really have a position on whether
there's evidence whether they do or
don't exist
i only think that it would be a relevant
piece of information you know because
let's say somebody argues that human
nature is fixed and then when humans and
aliens first mix or meat
some sort of weird transformation
happens by osmosis well okay that kind
of thing would have to be taken into
consideration but otherwise i'm agnostic
about i don't know enough about it i
used to be pretty sure well okay who's
this guy his name is like uh steven
drear or something like that
anyways
aliens probably do exist but i don't
really know the details yeah it is um uh
it is one of the questions that
fascinates me uh because if we
discovered aliens tomorrow it would be
absolutely mind-bending for billions of
people here on earth and it would have
an impact on so many different things
yet
when you think about the importance of
it
so few people actually care to think or
investigate it and so there's just this
dichotomy between uh wow that would be
pretty crazy uh but nobody really
cares too much so i don't know i just
find it very fascinating
yeah absolutely i mean thinking through
what would it be like what if they were
this what if they were that right what
would we have to change in our own
self-understanding if there were aliens
that's not my primary area but for sure
there's a lot to think about there and
in general you know there's so much
worth thinking about um
we need all the help we can get from the
old books up to date with our new
situation our new science our new
technology our new insights it's
brilliant you'll never be bored it's a
it's an amazing world and it's uh it's
there for us to consider
michael where can we send people to find
you on the internet or find out more
about the school or any of the books
that you've written
so the shortest link is
duganbook.com you'll see my two books my
school my newsletter my social media and
all of that i have a lot of free videos
on youtube on political philosophy and
that's where i would go duganbook.com
that'll take you everywhere else you
need to go
awesome well michael thank you so much
for your time today i've learned a ton
uh and i've really enjoyed looking into
not only the work that you've done
but but also just kind of your world
view and understanding how you think
about
investigating these individuals your
ability to separate a number of their
different ideas and really the
commendable ability that you have to
hold various ideas that may conflict
with each other kind of in your head at
once and not necessarily go in either
direction but just contemplate you know
where have we been what have people in
the past thought about and spoken about
and then what is the impact on today's
society and what does that mean for
where we're going it's it's a uh
a task that i don't think ever ends uh
but watching you do it and kind of
learning more about your work has been
pretty cool for me so i appreciate
taking the time to talk today
thanks it's been my pleasure